First, how to chop an onion.
This is the root.
That's absolute crucial, leave that on there.
If you cut that off, the onion will start to bleed and you'll start crying rapidly.
Slice going forward.
Let the weight of the knife do the work.
Three fingers, one in front, two behind...
...and this, part of the knuckle, is gonna guide the knife.
Fingers on top of the onion,...
...point the knife towards the root and try to get as close to the root as possible,...
...nice, long strokes.
And then, push the onion back together,...
...push the knife halfway in to the onion,...
...slightly tilt the knife down, one at the top,...
...and then, gripping the onion like a tennis ball, holding it together in place,...
...with the weight of the blade to cut through that onion...
...to get to the base of the root.
Again, turn it around, up and down motion.
And that's what we're left there: no waste, just the root.
And look, there, you've got a really nice, finely-chopped onion.